germany's Euroskeptic afd party is right
on track at least that's what business
woman fall cat paid way things the head
of the party's branch in the state of
saxony traveled to berlin the day after
the european elections we glad the AFD
has made it onto the international stage
and will make the most of our momentum
in state elections in the wake of their
european election success party members
are now preparing a roadmap for the
future state elections are being held in
saxony in august and Pete Lee is hoping
to enter parliament there the
conservative business woman is a highly
successful election campaigner afd
leader bent Luka greets her personally
at the party's headquarters the party
came in for widespread criticism in the
run-up to the European elections where
ever been Luka popped up so too did the
counter-demonstrations the protesters
choice of words was often a little below
the belt you're making things unclear
you want to return to the deutsche mark
out of fear you want a right-wing
germany these protesters sing
the Green Party supporters believe the
AFD deserves to be bad mouthed the idea
da FD insights racial resentment and is
against foreigners feminism and
homosexuals the AFD opposes the European
single currency and favors strong
nationalism over ties with Europe it
also wants to hear less English music on
the radio and only welcomes immigrants
it considers useful such sentiments have
traditionally been associated with
Germany's right-wing camp but some say
that's oversimplification these- based
on its policies I wouldn't describe the
AFD as a right-wing populists party from
an economic perspective it clearly
supports a free market and in the socio
political sphere I think it's a
nationalist and conservative party but
some people consider that nationalist
and conservative outlook problematic
funds [ __ ] man is a former party member
he says the AF DS definition of family
is very narrow and rooted in religion
and finds the party unaccepting of
alternative lifestyles Jennifer I'm
convinced the AFD doesn't tolerate
minorities why not by the echoes they
subscribe to 1950s era values the FD a--
the AFD is like old wine in old bottles
without strife and their arguments date
from the 1950s and rotten at least in
terms of these election results those
views seem to be gaining ground in
Germany but while much of the party's
current support can be attributed to a
protest vote bent Luka says it's the
numbers that count stop disdain crew
chief of Isis I think this is the
ultimate proof that a new party is
arriving in Germany I've already
referred to the fact that the AFD is a
party of the people we represent the
interests of a very diverse range of
voters from the highly educated to the
working class height of the intestine
dia Klein and Lord the seven afd
representatives about to enter the
European Parliament will now need to
join a faction Luca has already
distanced himself from right-wing groups
and other European countries
the AFD is hoping for closer ties with
Britain's conservatives escapes from
Adam we've already established contact
with the British conservatives who like
us suppose Central European government
like us they're in favor of a diverse
Europe rather than a simplified one and
like us they do not believe that we
should make debt in Europe a community
problem but Chancellor Angela Merkel is
reportedly using all her influence to
prevent such a cooperation isolating the
AFD and europe is a priority for her
she's already said conservatives in
Germany won't consider any coalition's
with the new party yah Martha we said
very clearly today that we won't
consider any cooperation that was the
unanimous opinion of our party's
executive committee this is the stance
that will adopt officially see vent Luca
has accepted that as a challenge he's
planning on contesting the next German
federal elections on the basis of his
party strong performance in European
elections the AFD is determined to enter
Germany state Parliament's next for now
it's pinning its hopes on figures like
Falcao Paisley we feel confident we got
10.1 percent of the European vote in
Saxony and we want to equal or exceed
that in the state elections from capital
you will spend the next three months
campaigning for a seat in Saxon 8 the
AFD has a clear goal it's determined to
use its european election success to
strengthen its national foothold in
germany
you